(festive music)
- Hi, my name's Dusty Rose
and I writing a letter to Santa.
It's a dream house RV with a kitchen.
And I hope, I hope I get it.
And my favorite thing
to do about Christmas
is decorate the tree.
And I love going to the snow
with my family in Colorado.
Bye!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Dusty Rose, you are so adorable!
I love you so much.
And what a great middle name,
might I add.
You remind me of my little river Rose.
All week everybody,
we've teamed up with
our season long partner,
Pilot Frixion Pen,
the go-to a erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
We're giving Santa an assist
with some Christmas wishlists.
And Dusty Rose,
we wanna celebrate creative
kids just like you,
so we are giving you a thousand dollars
to get your very own dream
house RV with a kitchen!
Merry Christmas!
And to everyone watching,
remember you can pick up
Pilot Frixion erasable pens
wherever office supplies are sold.